pour l'instant je voudrais vous
présenter son film à venir avec moi
parce que je vais présenter deux
personnes que j'aime beaucoup
pierre jean chalon sont qui est avec
nous aujourd'hui collectionneur français
d'argent merci d'être là père jean
deysel collectionneur français
principalement de rêver à napoléon
bonaparte et je vous connais très bien
parce que je vous dis je suis l'émission
tous les jours avant de venir à ces 8 j
adore je dors que j'adore à faire
conclut je suis à fond dedans mais c'est
vrai et lui c'est le beau gosse de
l'équipe la suisse ilan julien cohen qui
est avec nous qu'un homme d'affaires et
antiquaires français et les deux je vais
vous dire vraiment casting exceptionnel
aussi puisque vous avez trouvé des
formidables et des personnages
formidable voix je trouve vraiment bravo
à vous merci sans tout un timide elle a
des tendances en mieux maintenant béchir
sauf que tu vas bien
sophie tu vas dire près de moi ici parce
qu'ils vont nous présenter leurs objets
d'abord et on va leur dire on va leur
faire une estimation d'abord alors vous
c'est quoi donc un minitel première
génération minitel on est dans les
années
si tu avoir l'air d'un expert écran pc
merci merci
et ben voilà le créca mac lesggy oui le
faire
[Applaudissements]
une heure soit 483 première génération
minitel effectivement vous en attendez
entre 5000 et 10000 euros maintenant je
pense moi alors c'est moi ce soir j'ai
pris alors oui il est content il était
habité chez moi les velléités chômeurs
comme un contrat je pense que ça vaut
plus de 100 euros santoro fabrice
fabrice est ce qu'il fonctionne alors il
fonctionne parfaitement bien
elle fonctionne prise il ya même le
président téléphone il est la prise
électrique très bien et il fonctionne
alors il sert à rien parce que
maintenant il ya plus de réseaux voirie
tout ça c'est comme vous tous que je la
kiffe ça lâche away elle est
professionnelle jusqu'au bout des seins
j'ai même gardé un be bop
ah ouais ouais plus et sochaux connaît
pas garder ses vos femmes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais tous les jours alors combien
combien vous en mettez vous étiez non on
n'en veut pas moi ça me rappelle quand
j'étais gamin parce que je faisais 36 15
codes la vieille copine
ouais d'ailleurs je suis tombé dedans
quand j'allais acheter un bon père me
mettais foot acheter un minitel je dis
oui ça m'évite d'aller dans des bureaux
et après ça m'a coûté cher a coûté cher
à papa et moi on la coupe cela étant
c'est un peu comme dans l'émission de
voir ça me plaît à aujourd'hui mais que
c'est assez exceptionnel combattu mais
l'accord 2 euros 2 euros
combien julien c'est c'est super has
been quand même et c'est passé has been
pour voleurs de l'argent grâce à passer
comme nous 5e romanesque est ça qu est
ce que tu le costume miserait deux fils
et un bon tailleur on peut faire un truc
sa récente étude le 5e roue pas ce gars
est comme celui de la prod avec plaisir
[Rires]
à tout autant parce qu'il faut il faut
payer dans ce salon qui sait quoi
ouais personnel il ya 6 0 merci j'ai
bien aimé la cie toi c'est bon allez je
prends dans nos caves et 36 15 au mot
là-dessus quoi il met 36 cappato tu le
sais mais mes 36 15 au mot moi je le
sais mais bon bref c'est en tous les cas
voilà pourquoi la sexualité c'est
l'homme je t'ai connu mais on va pas
faire tout le monde c'est vraiment cette
région alors au début sophie je voulais
vendre non non non c'est à moi ça a
c'est à toi
fouetter mais je ne le vends piqué ça
moi je ne vends pas je le garde commence
par faire une scène alors en revanche
sans rire c'est collector c'est une des
dernières d'une série limitée il y en a
plus c'était la star d'nrj12 en
l'occurrence c'était moi les dédicaces
et c'était juste après housse pour la
petite histoire vous avez tiré à 100
donc les pour les fans de lanmeur c'est
la dernière et c'est également la
dernière avec cette couleur que j'avais
été me briand misandres et que je sais
plus aux gens magnifiques et comme la
tipp rôle énorme au risque ce qu'on voit
ça et passa pas les attaquer parce que
j'aime bien les autographes c'est pas
napoléon mais non bah c'est le jeu en
offrant 10 euros pour nos excuses pour
ce numéro mais sans lui donner aux
auditeurs d'nrj 12 toiles en effet pas
été simple non mais c'est toi je pense
que j'ai eu l'argent tu peut en offrir
un peu plus surtout si bien que livrer
chez toi alors 20 euros 20 euros 20
euros c'est pas mal mais c'est pas au
prix auquel je voulais le vendre à ce
que vous pourriez faire un énorme
attendiez combien j'en attendais 100
euros peut-être me sens heureux quoi
quoi t'es vu ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait
toute la chaîne on est monté à 2.8 des
délais
cinquante cinq ans en nombre au maximum
est fait pour ça mais pour un euro mais
qu'est ce que tu m'emmerdes 60 euros
soit 100 l'année qui était visé quand
même toutes les données c'est
l'animateur de ou 60 à 80 je cède je
prends ces bons 82 81 82 euros moi je
trouve un de mes lima 14 heures les
médias anglais 82 une blague alésien
racing attendait à toni 82 euros pour la
photo de delormeau oui mais non non
c'est pas la cgc de jeu solo et la photo
mais ça vaut qu'une balle
[Applaudissements]
oui l'argent que c'était la photo avec
un blouson la batsheva le garder alors
avec leur [ __ ] ou d'ailleurs et konaté
la photo qu'on met un x 82 chez toi 0 a
laissé les gens ne connaissaient 100 000
allez un dernier dossier très vite on a
30 secondes c'est pas été minées comme
ça tu seras tu sais quoi ça un objet du
19e je n'étais pas né un je le dis tout
ça dure et ça ça pose c'est un million
de russes yade soit pas l'accès du tout
et du rien pour m'amener à casser sa
tirelire au début de notre mariage pour
me l'offrir
merci mme entuber tu es tu vis toujours
avec ton mari l'avait payé savaria ce à
plusieurs centaines d'euros
c'est à dire plusieurs centaines comme
un séjour de sept cents us à votre mari
ce nom si un front là ouais à la saison
sesterces il a percé le temps des fêtes
voir enfin alors oui c'est qui ça ça
représente t il un polluant c'est à
henri iv setako aminullah un million de
rythme alors faire avant henri iv
commence à rayonner c'est quoi ça
voulait voir où je veux
oui vous allez nous là à nous donner
nous dire que moi ça vaut cette histoire
petites herm et baigneurs houppette
après il nous dit poussé by sap le miel
qu'il soit aurait quoi maximum entre 60
et 80 euros accor maximum un régime
fermé pire tu devrais commencer entre
les galaxies d'accord ouais vous le
vendez à 80 noms qu'ils aillent se faire
voir
[Rires]
quand la foudre
heureusement qu'on a des vendeurs
puissent impact va pas elle ne veut pas
tomber moi merci merci d'avoir été avec
nous pierre jean et julien merci d'avoir
avec elles et les dons mais revenez nous
voir quand vous voulez on est fan de
l'émission